foreign
Chicago hey Gary welcome to the Ramsey
Show
hey Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up
thanks for taking my call it's really a
pleasure
um my question is this my wife and I
about we're 50 years old uh about 10
years ago we figured out what we wanted
our retirement to look like and I should
mention they found you about one year
ago so pre Dave Ramsey we developed a
plan and we wanted our retirement to
look like a vacation property in kilo
Island a vacation property in Park City
Utah and somewhere else I've heard
primary home and so what we did was we
went out and bought a dental property
and both of those two locations I took
out a mortgage on both of those too
Ronald who still had a mortgage on our
primary residence as well for five years
since we bought those properties we got
them and then about five years ago we've
been short-term renting them big cash
flow positive they've been great we have
better than 50 equity in all three of
our properties our primary residence and
the two rentals but we realize that's
not the Dave Ramsey way but we've got a
good income a good net worth the cash
flowing positive we're about 10 years
away from retirement and this is like
our dream so I kind of want to know what
you would do it sounds like based on
your personal experience we've got some
risk
well I think everyone would agree that
debt equals risk and more debt equals
more risk
agreed
thank you very much yeah we have no
other Consumer Debt so that means you
have less risk than other people who
have a lot of debt but you have some
risk so I can't tell what it is so how
much Mortgage Debt do you have
real simple
each of the three properties our primary
residents we have a million and a half
of Mortgage Debt
correct but better than 50 Equity hurdle
each of those colors yeah okay and your
net worth is what one point I'm sorry
3.3 net worth
so we'll share the one and a half in
all right
so it's that's uh 401ks and uh brokerage
accounts okay
and how old are you guys
we're 50 and our household income is
four hundred thousand
okay
I'm not panicking about this
um the only thing I would adjust is
let uh you know here's the thing okay
it's not a Dave Ramsey thing
um it's just a when you when you scour
the people who have a net worth of 1 to
15 million we find in the data and we
did one of the largest studies of
millionaires ever done a few years ago
we find in the data some commonalities
meaning that their causal okay these
things caused people to have this net
worth uh one is they did what you did
they built a really nice retirement plan
nice 401K they usually got a million
million and a half like you've got in
your 401ks your brokerage accounts your
retirement accounts okay two is they
have paid for Real Estate they're home
so as an example a scaled down version
of where you are what we found in the
millionaire study a lot was a a guy or
gal a couple with a six hundred thousand
dollar paid for house and a million
dollars in a 401k so I got a million
dollar net worth a million 1.5 1.6 net
worth and there's zero debt and um we
find them at 52 years old a lot like
that like we found thousands of those
that were millionaires it sounded just
exactly like that
so what we've figured out is is that
paid for Real Estate going into
retirement having zero debt real estate
or anything going into retirement is a
stabilizing Factor
and it makes your retirement a lot less
stressful so you said you're 50
450 yeah and so if I woke up in your
shoes uh would I panic and go oh Dave
Ramsey says I gotta get out there no
this is all real estate debt okay but
you make 400 freaking thousand dollars a
year so how fast do we pay off with all
these rents coming in too how fast do we
pay off this million and a half well I'm
definitely going to do it in a decade
yeah so they met you and online what
we've been doing we've created a little
debt-free chart and what we've decided
to do is we've taken a rental property
with the highest interest rate on it and
we're going very intentional with that
one so all extra income whether it's
household or whether it's rentals going
to court against that one and then we'll
pay off the other rental and then what
we plan on doing is we retire is
whatever equities in our primary home
we're going to downsize into something
that size so we have no primary mortgage
on our primary home well or here's the
other thing your million eight will be
3.2 in seven years if it's in good
mutual funds
yep each of those yeah and so you reach
in there and touch it when you hit 60
and just pay it off and keep it if you
like the primary
you don't necessarily have to downsize
the primary how quickly can you pay off
a million dollars of the million and a
half well I've got the one has planned
it four years it's a half million on
that one so I would think two we could
do in eight years something quicker
because let's get one paid off exactly
yeah yeah yeah I'd like to see do the
whole thing in about eight
I think we can I think we can yeah so if
you get to 59 and a half you get
anything left just take a little out of
your retirement account and pay it off
if you like all three properties still
and you still like your plan the only
thing I did was disturb you about the
debt setting you up on a decade or less
to be clear of the debt if I'm in your
shoes I think that's fine and let me
tell you what will end up happening
you're going to get obsessed with this
you're going to end up doing it quicker
I've already I've already got a side
hustle with my income trust me she's
doing driving Uber making 400 guys what
is your side hustle do you mind us
asking uh yeah it's Logistics so there's
companies around Chicago that will help
you deliberately deliver things it's
like doing doordash but just not
doordash that's hilarious 400 000 and
he's got himself my wife my wife thinks
I'm nuts well you kind of are yeah you
kind of are what do you do what do you
do for a living
uh we're both in Sales Management so I I
didn't talk about the virtues of sales
careers we've been living sales our
whole life and couldn't change it for a
thing it's been great yeah well that's
the other thing here's what happens okay
as you now you have a new goal that's
got you fired up your sales are going to
go up
yeah but the level we are in sales now
we're out of the commission World we're
in the salary
we're in management now so it's salary
but you would if you're a commissioned
you know what I'm saying you know you
could do a side hustle with sales
training for non-competing companies
should make it a whole lot more doordash
thanks exactly just what do I know but
yeah anyway you're doing great man I'm
so proud of you it's so cool I
appreciate you getting fired up on our
stuff and all it's going to do is just
increase your peace level as those debts
start dropping off and even putting them
in the crosshairs and knowing when
they're going to drop off the piece
comes just from doing that even though
you haven't gotten there yet just
knowing you're going to be able to pull
the trigger and knock them out that's
the thing so yeah that that's beautiful
yeah you'll probably end up doing the
whole thing in about six years that's
gonna be my production my prediction and
uh just just this guy he he's mind is
already moving so that's what I mean we
see people do it all the time very
seldom do you hit your goals on this
stuff you almost always hit them early
that's right well when you're focused
right whether it's losing weight or
relationship growth when you're focused
towards a goal then what happens is
things begin to move in your favor that
you didn't see and we hear that all the
time and it's just a function of
intentionality and and and and Hyper
Focus activity and just Things Fall your
way and you know I actually would say
you know what you're getting bonus
probably on team performance instead of
the doordash I'd be working with these
individual team members that you and
your wife manage and Lead help them grow
help them hit new goals boy is that
going to be fun and probably going to
fatten those bonuses I would guess if I
was leading a sales team yeah you know
yeah I think there's a lot of stuff you
can do it's fun it's fun I mean um but
your your overall plan is not out of
control but keeping those debts forever
would not be my recommendation so let's
just develop a plan for getting rid of
them in some reasonable period of time
and uh and or when you hit 59 and a half
cash them out cash out because you're
going to be sitting on in excess of
three million dollars probably in excess
of four million dollars in those
retirement Accounts at that point not
counting your real estate and the real
estate will have continued to go up too
so you're going to you know you're going
to retire at 65 with a 7 million dollar
net worth give or take wow that's a
track you're on uh if you can especially
if you continue make a freaking 400
Grand you know that's that does help the
equation a little bit but um through
some number of those years so it's going
to put you in a great great place
um well Dave I can't be a baby steps
millionaire I don't make 400 Grand 33 of
the people that we found that became
millionaires in North America starting
from nothing with no inheritance did so
with an income less than one hundred
thousand dollars
the third most likely category of career
to become a millionaire in the study was
teachers number one was engineer number
two is account number three was teacher
so there you go those are facts
they're not wishes and they're not a
political statement so if you don't
agree with them you're what's known as
wrong this is the Ramsay show